[Musique]
mais quoi qu'ils aient un nom
le jury a l'embarras
non mais madame à tout ce ramdam assomme
la gamacherie d'un coup de coude oquendo
puis s'attaquent aux lois tout raciale
alors du fita larouche
le cobaty 10
c'est apparu clairement son 3 ainsi que
doit l'état le tout pour la somme sur la
route alors qu'ils désirent valve a
décidé c'est un bateau de tourisme alors
que c'est facile quid
désormais la troisième phase celle ci
est peut constater tout ce à quoi la
chine un poison bloqués à montréal c'est
bon c'est très préoccupant nous avons
trouvé une solution la solution c par
rapport aux stratégies que nous sommes
en train de monter pour que tous aillent
à l'école bien sûr c'est qu'ils sont ici
et ceux qui sont déplacés en interne
sont tous des enfants doivent être aidés
nous allons tout faire ils iront à
l'école